retracing the steps of the civil rights
march that took place on bloody sunday
and remembering loved ones they lost
my older brother jackie 17 years of age
taken away
for nothing
shot running like myself that day
running for cover
it's been a long road to truth and
justice and there's no end in sight
well i think murder is murder
and all the families will fight and
fight and fight for justice
and remain to fight and there's always
hope
it was january 30th 1972 when members of
the parachute regiment opened fire
following that civil rights march in
londonderry
14 people were shot dead but their
legacy lives on and they are not
forgotten
[Music]
ireland's prime minister tashak mahal
martin attended the memorial service
where relatives rejected the british
government's de facto amnesty for
veterans
but we send a very clear warning
to the british government
if they pursue their proposals
the bloody sunday families will be ready
to meet them head on
we will not go away and we will not be
silenced
this isn't just about what happened on
these streets 50 years ago it's about
what's happening politically today
because these families fear that the
british government's plan to halt
historical prosecutions could rob them
of their last chance of justice
the deputy first minister michelle
o'neill shares that concern as does her
party leader it's it's very humbling to
be here in derry 50 years on generations
on from that awful atrocity on that
awful day
and ironically at a time where the
british government now believes that
they can grant an amnesty and impunity
to their armed forces so there is a
there is a current political message
coming from this city of derry and from
across ireland
the victims were exonerated by a public
inquiry but without justice their
relatives say they cannot rest in peace
david blevins sky news in derry